はいこんにちは 、はじめしゃちょーです
はい、今回の動画はですね、
皆様、”尿”我慢したことありますか？
人というものは、こう水分というものを取り入れて、
体を循環させて、尿として排出して、
こう体の動きをね、こう作っているわけですよ。
つまり、すべての人間は
水分を取り入れて尿を排出する。
ですがこの中で、もし尿というものを我慢すると
どのような世界が見えてくるか。
我慢した先に何が見えるのかを、
今日はちょっと見ていきたいなと思います。
というわけで今からちょっと水分をちょっと取り入れた上で、
尿の限界を超えていこうと思うんですけども、
やっぱり我々二人だと不安なので、
今回は、
にお越しいただきます！
どうぞ！
入っていいよ～
僕、尿のスペシャリストじゃないですよ？
全然…はじめさん…たくみさん…
尿…尿…
にょー、にょー…（？）
はい、というわけで今回はこの三人で、ちょっと
尿を溜めた限界に迫ってみようと思います。
いや、実績があるんですよ
すっごいなんか尿を我慢した、みたいな。
（爆笑）
尿を我慢する事によると、ちょっと不思議な作用があるという情報をいれました。
僕の後輩からの情報なんですけども、
「知り合いの尿我慢大好きマンによると、 ー
…という、 天国に行ける感覚を味わえる」　、らしいです。
…っていう、　（爆笑）
まぁホースみたいにこう、”尿が部屋の中で尿まみれになる”っていう
地獄絵図が見れるらしいです。
情報が入っております。
あー…この後輩だったら結構ガチですね。
うん、結構本物です。
医学的根拠に基づく情報なので。
で、この状況で一人（ペットボトル）２本ずつ。
1L分、体に水分を蓄えます。
まぁ、増やしていくかもしれないけどね？
とりあえず三人とも同じ水分量にして、
誰が先に６時間尿を我慢してピリオドの向こう側にたどり着けるか。
はたまた６時間我慢に失敗して、ホースの覚醒に陥るか
さっそく、まずは水分を体に入れていきましょう！
いただきます…
あぁぁぁ
おおおえbsjsh
だいじょうぶっすか？マジで
結構来るよねえ
結構な尿意だよねぇ
怖いのは膀胱炎とかなんで
無理しすぎるとホントに身体に害が出るんで
自分の中のげんかいn
おいwミルクティーかよ　それはないよツリメッティｗ
まって、みて
ちょっと音聴いて　耳澄まして
wwwww
やば…
ツリメはこのレベルに行かないと…
ここで初めてピリオドの向こう側
ピリオドの臨界点に立てるから…
お腹タプタプいわないとピリオドの臨界t
おえええええgorgorgorgor
（皆さん大爆笑）
ちょっと待ってwwww
大丈夫？たくみ
うごおおおおおおおお（怪獣）
すばらしい…ｗ
ある意味ホースの覚醒ということで
はいというわけで気づくともう1時間経っておりました
何だろ…歩くとなんか…
ヒュンヒュンする
動いたらダメだもんね
ちょっと…
僕はちゃんと…
便器にしてきます…
こんなバカなことは止めましょう…
はいというわけで2人脱落したんですけども
正直僕ももう限界です…
多少の振動でも出そうになるレベルなんで
あ、だめだ
でるでるでる無理だ！
待ってぇ！！
頑張れ…
向こう側行きましょ
待ってヤバい…
これはもう、しゃちょー次第ですよ
意思の問題ですよ
はじめ、はじめ、はじめ、はじめ、はじめ……
（ちょろちょろちょろちょろ…）
あ ！あ！ あ！　ああああ！
テテレテレテレテレテレテレテレテレテレテレテレテレ
デュデュデュデュン
プシュップシュッ（はじめのすかしっぺ）